dr tiffany moon we don't get to say
doctor a lot in the housewives world how
are you feeling about this experience
i'm so excited i mean this is something
like i've never ever done before so
i took a leap of faith and i'm here for
it
i think most people are gonna wonder why
would someone with the title doctor
want to do reality tv so what's your
answer to that
my answer to that is that this is
something out of my comfort zone
it was an opportunity that was offered
to me that i really wanted to take
advantage of because i think
that young girls need to see more
doctors on reality tv
because we are real women you will see
me struggle
with balancing working as a physician
and having young children at home i
think people need to see more of that on
tv
instead of things that are you know
make-believe and glam and
not at all like most people's normal
lives
i can save your life but not your
reputation
how did this show come into your life i
know you were
friends with deandra and i believe you
popped up in the background of some
scenes
like eagle-eyed viewers might be able to
go back and watch old episodes but how
did the show come into your life
um d'andra is a good friend of mine mama
d
is a good friend of mine and yes i have
had
cameos on previous episodes um the
main one was for deandre's 50th birthday
party
and um she invited me to come along on
this fantastic adventure she promised me
that it would be fun
was it fun there were a lot of fun
moments
there was also a lot of introspection
a little bit of drama a little bit of
fighting
um but also a lot of fun gotta say it's
been really nice having a doctor around
she's sweet
and i'm sour is it you know the trailer
there's not a hint at what some big
drama might be so can you give me any
teases of what the big drama of season
five is what we need to be looking out
for
you know i don't know that there's big
drama i think this season will be a much
more
personal journey for everyone so
probably a little more real not that the
shows are even fake but focusing on
these real moments than what we've seen
in the past
it's like when all the noise dies down
and there's no more parties and no more
charity galas and you have to sit with
yourself
and you have a quiet moment of
reflection that's when you
actually can do yourself work all right
the group who is the most welcoming who
welcomed you with open arms
i will say um stephanie was really
welcoming i had known her peripherally
um through travis actually but um she
was
very welcoming and she's just so sweet
was anyone not welcoming
i mean what would you mean by not
welcoming
pushing someone into a swimming pool
when
i don't know some people were less
welcoming than others let's just keep it
at that
okay interesting that maybe the new girl
from last year wasn't welcoming to the
new girl this year that's what i'm
picking up here
what are you most excited for the fans
to experience this season
i am just hoping that people
see us like see the true us
and i i hope that we can make people
laugh because it has been a tough year i
have cried more tears in 2020 i swear
than the past five years combined
so i want to laugh and i want to make
other people laugh so if you watch the
show and you chuckle and giggle
and um you know get some good one-liners
then my job is done or maybe you and
deandra falling out of a swing
that hurt i would imagine it maybe looks
like um
a little alcohol-induced moment there
that
um we may have had some alcoholic
beverages prior to that
happening on the flip side of what
you're excited for the fans to
experience is there any moment you know
that you're not gonna want to see back
on tv
i don't know there's nothing that i
really regret saying
i'm i'm proud of what we did
and i'm excited to see the show so kind
of on that note what do you want the
viewers to know about you
going into that first episode i just
want them to know
that um i'm here for the right reasons
this is my true story i hope
to um educate and to inspire
and and to entertain people what was
your
relationship with housewives before
obviously you're friends with some of
these ladies but were you a fan of the
franchise
in general had you just dipped in what
was your relationship with the show
i will admittedly say that i was not
um a watcher of the housewives
um i'm not a watcher of tv in general um
if you put me in front of the tv
i will probably be asleep within 10
minutes well i think that might be good
coming in with fresh eyes not having
some expectation of what you're supposed
to deliver just being yourself
um and going back to the trailer i want
to unpack a couple moments
we hear you say in the trailer be honest
i know that's really hard in this group
who's the least honest person in this
group oh
i don't know we've all said things that
we should not have
said and i think you will see that um
come out during the season all right we
also see carrie
call you two-faced you're very two-faced
i'm not choosing
what leads to that moment what can you
tease me with about that conversation
we were having a nice group lunch and
i thought we were just you know tasting
some wine and hanging out
and she voiced some concerns about some
of my behaviors
so you will get to see my response
to her calling me two-faced um on that
episode
she also take kindly to that
understandably so she also implies that
you're bossy
all she does is give orders yeah you
know bossy is a loaded word because we
never
call men bossy we only call women bossy
and it almost has a negative connotation
to it like
you were telling people what to do
yeah i mean if that's the definition of
bossy then i am bossy
i'll tell people what to do at work in
order to save patients lives
i'll tell people how to act when they're
in my home
at a party that i'm you know serving
them
and i'll tell my husband and kids what
to do sometimes
so if she wants to call me bossy that's
just fine with me
i love it reclaim the word reclaim it
a more serious moment in the trailer you
have a conversation with brandy about
the racist video that resurfaced uh
between
seasons four and five what you did was
wrong you know that
what can you tell me about the journey
brandy's going to go on because i would
imagine
you wind up being a sounding board for a
lot of stuff
yeah um you know it was really
unfortunate that that video resurfaced
my being on the show has nothing to do
with that video
and i do address it because i think it's
important
um to make it sort of a teachable moment
for her
but i think she
knows that what she did was wrong and
she
has um i guess
repented and um goes through a very
personal journey
which i think we'll see unfold during
this season
when your casting was confirmed kind of
this celebration of
more representation on tv an asian
housewife who has a unique story to
share what does it mean to you to bring
more representation to tv
oh gosh it means so much to me that we
are seeing more color on tv people
of asian american ethnicity as well as
african-american ethnicity just
everything because i will tell you when
i moved to the united states in the
early 90s
and i got to watch tv as a treat
there was no one that looked like me so
i thought that i was
not ugly but just not special or that
anyone who looked like me could never
you know
be on tv um and i just think it's so
important for little girls to have role
models that they can look up to
um that look like them i mean i think
that representation
really does matter to wrap things up
here if you had to describe
season five of the real housewives of
dallas in just
one word what is your word for it
oh gosh i would say
fresh cheers cheers thank you for
having me now we're in the closet so i
have to ask some closet specific
questions how many berkins are in there
with you
um are we just birkins no kelly's i'm
gonna
[Music]
all right if we include the kelly's in
any other hermes bags
all right i hope there's some good
security in your house oh we have good
security
people are always like are you worried
about them coming for these birkins i'm
like well first i'll have to get past
the guard and they'll have to get past
the gate
and then they'll have to get past my
husband who sleeps with a gun in his
nightstand
so if you want a birken that bad
okay join a waiting list instead maybe
join a waiting list instead it's easier
than getting shot
or going to jail please or i'll
let you borrow one really